another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr bright no  more mocking scp-008's victims just  because they're zombies doesn't mean  it's okay to bully them playing the  michael jackson song thriller in the  presence of scp-008 victims is strictly  prohibited it is also not acceptable to  try and simulate video games using  victims of zero zero eight this includes  but is not limited to letting them out  of captivity and punching them in order  to simulate minecraft couldn't you just  dig for precious minerals instead and  pushing agents in front of scp-008  victims in order to simulate resident  evil dr bright is no longer allowed  within 50 feet of any victims of scp-008